on va parler d'un sujet qui a beaucoup
fait parler c'est l'histoire de ma vie
donc c'est un jeune fdr jeune sdf qui
après avoir reçu un énorme élan de
solidarité sur twitter nous montre
depuis peu une phase bien plus on vous
allez voir on a un garçon qui va venir
nous rejoindre un instant c'est philippe
moreau chevrolet s'est il est directeur
d'une grande société de communication il
va nous expliquer les dérives autour de
cet emballement médiatique vous allez
nous expliquer vous savez plein d'infos
là dessus vous avez même eu la famille
de la personne à qui a lancé cet élan de
générosité c'est parti c'est le big boss
de tous les médias ont parlé ces
derniers jours
18 ans will a ému les internautes my
league
un garçon sans abri à la gueule d'ange
de 18 ans dont l'histoire a
particulièrement ému les internautes
tout commence le 25 août dernier avec un
tweet de kim une jeune femme qui
bouleversée par sa rencontre avec my
league dans les rues de paris invite les
internautes à un acte de solidarité
envers lui de là tout s'emballe des
milliers d'euros tweets et la presse
s'empare du phénomène de nombreuses
personnes vont à sa rencontre dans la
rue pour lui apporter du soutien
mais ce qui aurait pu être un magnifique
conte de vacances a tourné court une
femme qui avait hébergé le jeune homme
porte plainte pour le vol de son porte
monnaie et son téléphone portable je me
suis fait rouler par my league
je crois qu'il faut prévenir tous ceux
qui lui viennent en aide une autre femme
aurait retrouvé dans ses affaires une
pipette de crack depuis mai ligue a été
condamné à 140 heures de travail
d'intérêt général
alors selon vous les médias se sont ils
emballent et trop vite dans cette
affaire alors c'est vrai que cette
histoire est folle vous avez suivi un
peu de cette histoire marouane je suis
sûr que je suis sûr que tu as tu suivi
l'histoire un mais c'est ouf parce que
tout le monde alors donc on va rappeler
encore les les faits valérie benaïm
c'est une jeune femme qui rencontre ce
garçon elle elle a envie de tendre la
main parce qu'il est jeune parce que
elle elle se dit que un élan de
solidarité c'est facile à faire
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux dont
quel poste une petite vidéo elle poste 1
un lien twitter en disant écoutez voilà
il faut absolument était ce garçon il se
trouve qu ensuite on sait en creusant un
peu on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
quelques petites casseroles on va dire
et notamment une histoire où il aurait
hébergé par une gamme et il aurait un
dérober des choses enfin qu'il n'était
pas aussi dans le besoin que ça que son
papa le
là aussi à la maison s'il veut enfin
qu'il n'est pas à la rue en fait
d'accord alors théaux a eu la famille de
la jeune fille il va nous dire dans quel
état allié la scientifique a lancé
l'élan de solidarité il ya philippe
moreau chevrolet qui est venu nous
rejoindre vous êtes directeur d'une
grande société de communication et vous
êtes nos talons spécialiste des
questions autour de l'emballement
médiatique et c'est vrai que cette
affaire a été relayée partout dans les
médias comme m6 europe 1 forcément voilà
tout le monde à relier et c'est vrai que
douala sur des surdités sur des sites
tout le monde a relayé cette affaire est
ce que vous trouvez
franchement que les médias se sont trop
emballé sur cette affaire oui puis ça
reposait sur rien sans reposer sur une
blogueuse qui avait rencontré un mec
mignon dans la rue dans le 8e
arrondissement incarne plutôt rassurant
pour ceux qui connaissent pas 8e
arrondissement c'est très rassurant donc
ils n'ont pas choisi n'importe quel spot
non plus pour mettre son carton et puis
il la tchatche et il lui racontait pas
mal de raconter sa vie en étant très
émouvant très sincère elle a craqué la
ruée sur les réseaux sociaux et le
parisien a repris l'info sans vérifier
la réalité du truc alors le parisien
puisse germer dans leur boulot à
d'habitude mais là c'est vrai quoi là
ils sont donc vérifiez toujours ces
infos méric césar vidéo en fait ils ont
retrouvé une simple vidéo ils n'ont pas
fait un travail d' enquête c'était juste
une vidéo pour le site web
mais c'est sur la vidéo il crève l'écran
il est mignon m'adapte bien et on y
croit à fond il a 18 ans donc il a l'air
innocent et tout est en fait c'est après
qu'ils se rendent compte qu'ils
s'étaient fait avoir mais alors monde
c'est fait vous avez eu la jeune fille
qui a lancé l'élan de solidarité aux
familles a vu sa maman alors maintenant
j'ai vu la jeune fille elle même qui m'a
expliqué qu'elle m'a elle qui m'a
exactement qui est plus bas que terre
parce qu'elle se prend un tas de déchets
dans la tronche en ce moment sur les
réseaux sociaux alors que la pauvre
enlever sa photo la pauvre que les voilà
qui est alors pauvre a seulement voulu
aider ce pauvre maelig de bonne foi et
là elle se prend à revers à un retour de
bâton qui est abominable par contre en
revanche j'ai eu la famille du jeune
malick pour j'ai eu le père qui m'a
plutôt envoyer chier non exactement
adéquat parce que en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ce jeune homme a été
arrêté et n'a pas fugué de chez lui ou
quoi que ce soit il a été évincé de chez
lui dont il est dans une situation
compliquée il faut pas qu'on parle trop
vite qu'on avance trop vite sur la sur
la faire mais on connaît pas tellement
cette histoire à ce monsieur il faut
faire attention
d'accord très bien gilles moi ce qui me
choque effectivement c'est l'emballement
médiatique mais ça date pas d'hier dit
aujourd'hui à la concurrence via les
réseaux sociaux il ya eu plein de
faire sur une eau de la sphère baudis à
l'époque avait été accusé de tous les
maux il était à l'époque patron du csa
il avait dû aller sur le plateau de
claire chazal lieu d histoire effroyable
c'est vrai que les médias parfois ferait
mieux de ralentir et veut vérifier alors
qu'il ya des infos sur cette affaire là
dessus alors tu es ou encore et j'ai
également contacté aussi des amis
d'enfance de ce my league
adacore qui pour la plupart ça les
étonne pas en fait malick c'est
quelqu'un qui était un garçon qui avait
énormément de problèmes pendant sa
scolarité qui accable cas pas toujours
été facile avec ses professeurs avec ses
camarades et de l'endroit où il vient de
chalon de châlons en champagne ça
n'étonne personne
d'accord est incluse oui le fait qu'il
est été très médiatisée que sa photo
soit paru partout à réveiller votre
plein c'est à dire que dix ans qu'on dit
mais je le reconnais mais aussi il nous
a posé nos escrocs souligné que les gens
lui en veulent pas c'étaient des filles
à qui il a piqué le portefeuille et son
iphone
elle lui en veut pas elles veulent aider
aujourd'hui elle est allée le voir au
commissariat ils ont pleuré ensemble une
confrontation est aujourd'hui a dit elle
va essayer de l'aider et la blogueuse
qui là qu'il a aidé au départ veut
continuer à l'aider donc il ya quelque
chose chez ce garçon qui dépasse quand
même voilà qui touche les gens
visiblement c'est cela oui
mathieu moi ce qui m'agace c'est une
femme attend les pieds dans le plat mais
les chaînes d'info font beaucoup de tort
à l'info c'est ça le problème
à l'époque alors on voit pas qui est sûr
c'est nous senio dit tu vas comprendre à
l'époque il y avait quelques chaînes et
journée toute la journée en cap et voilà
c'est pas une chaîne d'info qu'un repris
en or mes jambes toute la journée les
chaînes enquêtait le soir y'a un truc
qui sortait au vainqueur comme
maintenant c'est la cour des quais news
faut la sortir tout de suite avant
quelqu'un d'autre la saur emerson
enquête et on la sort comme sur ainsi
fait compris les accusés alors sur un
truc personne n'est heureux sur les
conséquences pour ce petit personnes
bien qu il n'a pas non plus fait un
drame exceptionnel
bon il a menti il est jeune il a menti à
son fonctionnement à lui c'est vrai que
vu les prix ce qui se passe autour de
lui vaut le chef voulait frapper mais si
on me dit si on me dit après demain
s'est suicidé ça m'étonnera pas je veux
dire tout ce qui se passe autour de ça
je vois ce jeune comme il est il est
quand même fragile
quand tu fais des conneries qu'on me
fait la cia camille fragilité aussi à
quelque part qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
venue avant qu'ils sont de la famille ou
de sa vie donc ce jeune là quand même
il faut quand même le protéger il a fait
des conneries c'est une chose comme ça
va faire des travaux d'intérêt public
c'est bien mais il faut quand même le
protéger aussi parce que là il faut
quand même le faire gaffe à tout ça
alors je vois mon fils moi alors ça
m'inquiète un peu voilà j'aimerais pas
que ce soit mon excuse à la situation la
seconde doit son fils et puis par là on
a on a tous peur de devenir sdf pourquoi
ça marche cette histoire parce que tout
le monde a peur de devenir sdf moi j'ai
des clients extrêmement riche il rêve
encore la nuit ils ont encore des
cauchemars de tous
berne en fait c'est quelque chose qu'on
a tous c'est pour ça que ça marche et
puis c'est vrai qu' on dirait notre
gamin quoi moi juste pour dire oui à
l'emballement médiatique
ah oui quand même oui parce que s'il n'y
aurait pas eu cet emballement on
n'aurait pas découvert qu'il aurait et
grâce à l'emballement on peut savoir
qu'il est on voit tout de suite qu'il va
grâce à des notes
voilà qui n'a pas sa place et grâce à
l'emballement on sait qu'il a qu'il
acquit la voilà qui l'a donc la rue
c'est faux non c'est pas ce que je dis
mais l'emballement médiatique permet de
déceler que celui là il n'a pas
paranaque et plus de personnes alors
merci l'info on va voir on va voir le
sondage twitter les médias sont
rutilants balé de rua oui bien sûr non à
13%